what's going on guys welcome to the
third ease of movement tutorial video in
this video what we're going to be doing
is actually plotting up the ease of
movement
indicator if you don't already have it
you're going to need the starting sample
of the code so this is where it is the
link is in the description just uh start
top here go down copy and paste this
whole thing
into an empty script so i'll print mine
there and then right up right between
these two comments here is where we're
going to spit some code in here so we're
going to take this right here
and just to the definition of emv and
then calling emv that's what we really
need so copy that come over here paste
it
and fix your indentation with a couple
of tabs there
and now we're ready to define some new
code and fix our screen a little bit
and let's make the text big
okay so now uh really what we need is x
e m v
y
e and v equals this because this returns
like two variables right the date and
the uh actual value
now all we need to do is ax2 dot
uh plot
uh x emv oops xenv
y emv what color do we want it we'll
plot it as white let's go ahead and run
that see what we got going so far
so we'll plot up ebay
and so here's the first thing that we
get
um so it looks like it's working
sure enough you know like as it's
falling okay ease of movement goes down
and stuff and looks just like the one i
showed you
um
in the first introductory video
so that's always good now
um now what we might want to do is add
that horizontal line if you've been
following the tutorial video you already
know how to do this but we'll throw it
in just in case and so it's going to be
ax2.axh
line where's that line want to be at the
zero what color does it want to be i
heard it wants to be white
next
uh
what do we want we want to add like that
label right so plot dot
y
label what do we want that label to say
before i say what it is so it's an emv
not an asterisk it's a 14.
and
then what color does it want to be it
also wants to be white so we can
actually see it
so let's plot again we'll plot ebay
again
and
here is um
ebay and now we have that center line
and we have you know the little uh
label for it
so that's going to conclude the ease of
movement indicator within python and
matplotlib hopefully you guys enjoyed
learned something you cared about as
always thanks for watching thanks for
all the support and subscriptions until
next time